tout tentative de violation de l'espace
aérien national fera objet d'une riposte
énergique et instantanée face aux
menaces d'une intervention armée des
pays d'Afrique de l'Ouest la gente
militaire ayant pris le pouvoir au Niger
le 27 juillet dernier ne montre aucun
signe de faiblesse l'ultimatum transmis
au puchis par la Communauté économique
des États de l'Afrique de l'Ouest
exigeant un rétablissement de l'ordre
constitutionnel sous peine
d'intervention armées à expiré dimanche
soir sans aucun effet près de 30 000
partisans du coup d'État militaire
c'était rassemblé ce jour-là dans un
stade de Niamey arborant notamment des
drapeaux Russes et des portraits des
nouveaux dirigeants
la libération totale du Niger
on est fatigué
le général Mohammed Toumba numéro 3 de
la gente militaire a pris la parole pour
dénoncer ceux qui sont en train de
manigancier la subversion contre la
marche en avant du Niger les contours
d'une possible intervention militaire
avait été définie vendredi dernier par
les chefs d'état-major des 15 pays
membres de la CEDEAO auquel c'était juin
le Sénégal et la Côte d'Ivoire nous
condamnons la tentative de coup d'État
au Niger qui constitue une grave menace
pour la paix et la sécurité dans la
sous-région une position appuyée avec
fermeté et détermination par Paris dont
les 1500 soldats postés dans ce pays du
Sahel ont été priés de plier bagages
mais craignant de voir la région plongée
dans le chaos plusieurs voies africaines
ont rejeté ces derniers jours l'option
militaire le président algérien
abdelmadji je teboun a estimé qu’une
intervention serait une menace directe
pour son pays tandis que les sénateurs
du Nigéria pourtant membres de la CEDEAO
ont appelé leur président bolatinubu a
renforcé une option politique et
diplomatique le Burkina Faso est le Mali
voisin du Niger et eux aussi gouvernés
par des militaires ont de leur côté
réaffirmé qu'une intervention militaire
serait considérée comme une déclaration
de guerre alors deux pays pendant ce
temps les militaires nigériens
renforcent leur pouvoir les Pucci sont
annoncé lundi la nomination d'un nouveau
Premier ministre à limahaman laminésie
alors que le président Bazoom est
toujours séquestré dans sa résidence
privée le CDAO va se réunir jeudi à
Abuja pour un sommet extraordinaire en
attendant la diplomatie américaine s'est
activée Washington crainte en effet de
voir ses intérêts miniers mis à mal
notamment dans l'exploitation de
l'uranium
c'est Victoria newlord numéro 2 de la
diplomatie américaine par intérim qui
s'est rendu au Niger lundi pour prendre
part aux discussions elle dit avoir
proposé au chef d'état-major Moussa
salahoubarmou de nombreuses options pour
revenir à l'ordre constitutionnel tout
en ajoutant je ne dirais pas que cette
offre a été prise en compte de quelques
manières que ce soit le spectre du
groupe paramilitaire russe Wagner déjà
présent au Mali voisin inquiète
Washington les auteurs du coup d'État
comprennent très bien les risques que
fait courir à leur souveraineté une
invitation de Wagner
[Musique]